[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce journal d'information locale
nous sommes le jeudi 20 janvier voici
les titres de cette édition
sa divine numérique fête ses 5 ans
objectifs du syndicat déployer le très
haut débit sur le territoire et
développer des services bilan cinq ans
après sa création quels projets à venir
et nous évoquerons aussi l'installation
de la fibre dans le département qui
touche à sa fin il a conçu les arcades
du lac à montigny le bretonneux ricardo
beau fils est décédé mardi l'architecte
espagnol novateur a participé à la
construction de près de 600 logements à
saint quentin en yvelines retour sur son
parcours le yoga vignes asa c'est
l'alliance entre le sport et le
bien-être au programme exercices de
respiration et postures pour solliciter
les muscles profonds quelle différence
avec le yoga classique et découverte de
cette discipline dans ce journal
et nous parlerons également de virtual
classe est une plateforme de soutien
scolaire lancée par une jeune chinoise
mais aussi les circonscriptions du
département à suivre pour les
législatives
[Musique]
il vibre est sur le point de raccordés à
la fibre les deux dernières commune
yvelinoise de son contrat alain ville et
par et doivent ils devraient en
bénéficier à la fin du printemps
prochain un raccordement dans le
département qui a débuté en 2019 les
précisions de mélanie poké des travaux
qui ont débuté sur la n191 les équipes
d'yveline fibre vont bientôt relier les
communes d'allainville et de parler
doivent ils à la fibre ce sont les deux
dernières villes concernées par les
chantiers divine fibre les défis autour
de la ville et paris doivent il sait que
ce sont des bourgs mais il ya également
des hameaux qu'il faut aller chercher
donc on était jeunes et en chercher un
sur paris doit ville qui s'appelle
aubeville est lui qui est déjà ouvert
mais par contre il ya aussi pas mal de
fermes isolées et donc là on a des
travaux de génie civil sur sur également
plus - kilomètres pour aller chercher
différents hameaux avec ce dernier
chantier ils viennent fibre aura équipé
150 communes près de quatre ans de
travaux qui représente 5000 km de câbles
et 200 km de tranchées le territoire
yvelinois
augmente en terme de population en
termes de maison donc il ya des nouveaux
collectifs il ya des nouvelles maisons
qui se construisent et toutes ces
maisons là où tous ses nouveaux
collective il faut continuer à les
rendre éligibles à la fibre donc on a
aujourd'hui un pas mal de chantiers qui
sont en cours à dire que les promoteurs
nous consultent pour savoir comment ils
peuvent raccorder leurs programmes
immobiliers à la fibre optique contenu
que orange ne propose plus de cuivre
dans ces nouveaux bâtiments donc pour
que les gens est internet c'est la fibre
rien du tout les déploiements
aujourd'hui de 95 % a débuté en avril
2010 neuf du côté des vêtements et de
sept autres communes
et déployer des services numériques sur
le territoire assez la mission de ces
livres numériques et pour en parler vous
êtes avec nous bertrand que carbon soir
bonsoir vous êtes un le président de
seine yvelines numériques vous
travaillez notamment donc en
collaboration avec l'ines fibres dont on
vient de voir le reportage c'est navy
amérique donc fait ces cinq ans je
lisais en titre tout à l'heure cette
année quel bilan vous dressez de ses
cinq années d'existence
eh bien oui un bilan qui est très bon on
a on a agi sur sur trois principaux axes
on en a parlé le c'est important de
déployer la fibre dans la zone publique
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui le déploiement
de lachy peut-être fait sur une zone je
dirais privé qu'on appelle ami dans
lequel les des opérateurs investissent
parce que souvent c'est très rentable et
vous avez les zones plutôt rurale zone
publique dans lequel ça coûte un peu
d'argent on a fait un montage a
effectivement avec yveline à chypre pour
pouvoir s'assurer que 95% du territoire
des yvelines pour être couvert même les
petits hameaux et les petites fermes est
ce le cas on vous l'a dit on va terminer
avec les deux derniers à rebours en 2021
ça représente quand même près de 103
mille foyers qui ont été chiffrés de
même que l'intégralité des collèges qui
était un axe important aussi pour le
département et pour ça des yvelines
numériques
justement vous venez d'en parler je vais
rebondir là dessus parce que
l'équipement numérique des élèves
justement et des collégiens c'est aussi
votre un peu votre cheval de bataille où
est-ce qu'on en est aujourd'hui est-ce
que vous avez un peu des chiffres à nous
donner un bilan là dessus aussi
absolument là ce qui est vraiment
primordial c'est de pouvoir s'assurer
d'un débit rapide donc la fille on nous
a permis de le faire à partir de là on a
pu avoir un pilote que l'on a fait dans
17 collèges pendant trois ans en
collaboration et que l'éducation
nationale dans lequel on a déployé pour
les 6e et les 5e et les enseignants ont
plus de 11000 tablettes où on dirait un
cartable numérique est composé d'une
tablette et d'outils à applicatifs et de
sécurisation et on a un bilan qui est
extrêmement bon puisque à l'issue de ces
trois ans on a vu le niveau progresser
dans les classes équipées à de bas
niveaux pour les mathématiques et le
français ou encore plus pour les zones
les collèges on n'arrête plus vous savez
en zone défavorisée donc ça fonctionne
le taux d'utilisation est montée
crescendo jusqu'à plus de 60 % dont il
une vraie adhésion du corps enseignant
et des élèves donc on en est très très
satisfait il en parlera après dans les
projections sur les années à venir mais
on pense qu'on pourra aller l'étendre au
bloc communal halles à partir du cm1 et
éventuellement à tous les collèges si
alou cei départementale le spa ti
pour pouvoir anticiper si on compare
l'accès au numérique sur le territoire
avec le département des yvelines
justement avec d'autres départements où
est-ce qu'on se situe à peu près on est
à 95% du du territoire couvert en haut
débit grâce à l'implication très
importante du conseil départemental
comme je l'expliqué sur les sur les
zones publiques ça fait quasiment
jeudi 95% du territoire couvert donc
c'est plutôt très très satisfaisant
est-ce qu'on fait partie du traitement
des départements qui sont le plus
couvert où il ya le plus axé finalement
à sony mérite absolument on a fini
s'était fait partie du plan de l'état
qui nous avait donné jusqu'en 2023 pour
tout fibre et on a fini deux ans avant
donc on est très fiers effectivement les
on est avant gardiste l'addition les
parties de foot au hand et 2016 c'est
aussi pour ça qu'ils étaient là qu'a été
créé le syndicat mixte ouvert avec 300
adhérents qui est sa ligne unique
là pour pour 2022 plusieurs projets ont
déjà été lancés comme par exemple
l'équipement individuel mobile dont ont
parlé et qui se poursuit pour 2022 vous
lance également une offre dédiée aux
collectivités sur la vidéoprotection de
la voie publique autre enjeu c'est la
protection dans le domaine du numérique
avec la cyber sécurité je voulais faire
un point là-dessus avec vous parce que
ça fait quoi sur le territoire puisque
l'année dernière plusieurs collectivités
yvelinoise ont été victimes de cyber
attaques comment vous vous engagez sur
ce sujet c'est effectivement important
la cyber sécurité aujourd'hui où la fée
des matinales a asséné du numérique qui
permettent d'accueillir un petit peu
tous les différents acteurs et je
retiens le mot d'un des mères qui était
attaqué qui disait ce n'est plus une
question de est-ce qu'on va se faire
attaquer ou essaie plutôt de temps et
donc il faut que ces collectivités
territoriales et locales soit armé pour
ça on a une offre qui l'on va déployer
qui est sur deux axes qui est une offre
je dirais complète en termes
d'équipement de recommandations et de
suivi et une offre qui pique à l'adresse
des communes en termes d'équipement
plutôt logiciels de sécurisation et on
va déployer cette offre à partir de 2021
ça va vraiment de l'analyse du système
informatique voir s'il ya des frei à la
préconisation d'un matériel et à une
solution d'intervention également par
des gens et des entreprises tpe du qui
ont été sélectionnés pour devenir
intervenir rapidement puisque évidemment
le l'idée c'est que où les collectivités
attaquer les pas à payer de rançons et
ne soient pas immobilisées trop
longtemps donc ça c'est un des services
pour 2022 peut-être dernière question
avant de vous quitter justement quels
sont les autres actualités j'ai
brièvement effleuré à quelques salles ce
que vous allez proposer que vous
proposez déjà mais pour 2022 quels sont
les autres actualités à venir
deux actualités très rapide vous l'avais
dit la vidéoprotection sur la voie
publique c'est quelque chose qui est
très important qui coûte de l'argent
aujourd'hui on a des polices municipales
qui se déploie mais qui sont en capacité
d'être derrière des écrans
7 jours sur 7 et 24 heures sur 24 c'est
quelque chose que pourra proposer le
syndicat à travers un centre de
supervision urbain la loi a changé et
permet maintenant à des agents de
pouvoir regarder les images et
interpellés soit la police nationale
soit les polices municipales directement
et donc de faire bénéficier d'une
sécurité accrue donc c'est une offre que
l'on que l'on adresse également au bloc
communal ou intercommunal une offre
importante qui est demandé et le dernier
point on a parlé du déploiement des
véhicules électriques aujourd'hui il ya
besoin d'avoir des bornes de recharge
surtout sur le territoire rural avec
quelques adaptations donc on est aussi
engagée sur le déploiement de bornes de
recharge pour les véhicules électriques
que ce soit l'installation la gestion
mais également la maintenance donc c'est
un des points forts et là il y en ad
autres un des mercenaires pour des
meurtres alisation mais ce sont trois
axes forts du syndicat pour pour les
années à venir voilà ce sont les gros
projets on va dire pour pour les années
à venir comme vous le dire par fait
coûté c'est bien noté merci pour ces
explications à bertrand coq à main c'est
d'avoir été avec nous et je le rappelle
vous êtes le président le président
pardon de seine yvelines numériques
[Musique]
sarah guy annan à seulement 16 ans et
pourtant elle est la fondatrice de
virtuel classe une plate forme d' aide
scolaire en ligne les cours sont
dispensés par les étudiants du supérieur
et sont totalement gratuits le reportage
de célia gars tsongo et margot gésiers
saraghina 16 ans elle est lycéenne et
lors du premier confinement elle décide
de créer virtuel classe la classe
virtuelle c'est tout simplement en fait
une plateforme j'irai où on a mis en
lien des professeurs bénévoles qui sont
généralement des étudiants qui aspirent
à devenir professeurs et des élèves de
tous niveaux quand je dit haut niveau
c'est soit des personnes en difficulté
ou d'immersion qui souhaitent se
perfectionner et c'est un vrai succès
aujourd'hui 15 étudiants du supérieur
sont professeurs bénévoles et une
centaine d'élèves en première année de
terminale profite de ses cours en
visioconférence généralement ils
viennent de france du coup il arrive
qu'on en ait qui viennent de l'étranger
qu'ils en programmes français les jeunes
doivent simplement remplir un formulaire
d'inscription disponible sur le site
sarah elle même élève de 1ère
participent aux cours et consacrent une
grande partie de son temps libre à la
gestion de cette plateforme elle combine
cette activité avec son planning de
lycéennes déjà bien chargé non je trouve
que c'est pas si compliqué que ça faut
juste trouver une organisation là en ce
moment bas j'y travaille
souvent parce qu'en fait télé seront du
bac de français qui viennent c'est
samedi pour le moment les cours sont
uniquement adressé aux étudiants en
première année de terminale mais sarah
souhaite ouvrir la plateforme à d'autres
niveaux dans les années à venir
et le monde de l'éducation au bord de la
rupture plusieurs syndicats comme le
snes fsu la cgt ou encore la fcpe ont
appelé à la grève ce jeudi 20 janvier
elle fait suite à la mobilisation de
jeudi dernier notamment le personnel
scolaire est en colère il dénonce un
protocole sanitaire inapplicable dans
les écoles et demandent des prises de
décisions claires dans l'académie de
versailles le taux de participation au
mouvement de grève de ce jeudi 20
janvier était de 2% pour les enseignants
du premier degré 3 % pour le second
degré selon les chiffres de l'académie
est des chiffres en baisse par rapport à
la semaine
jeudi 13 janvier le taux de
participation s'élevait à 43 % pour le
premier degré 22% pour le second degré
est toujours selon les chiffres de
l'académie une grève pourrait être
reconduite le 27 janvier prochain
[Musique]
et notre dossier de la semaine est
consacrée aux élections législatives de
2022 focus aujourd'hui sur la 2e
circonscription à des yvelines en 2017
elle a basculé au centre avec le modem
et la majorité présidentielle de la
république en marche un basculement
alors que l'été est ancrée à droite
depuis 1958 s est aussi le berceau
politiques et des premiers mandats de
valérie pécresse les anges sur ce
territoire entre versailles grand parc
et la vallée de chevreuse avec nikola
dandrès
la 2e circonscription des yvelines
devrait attirer de nombreux regards une
circonscription représentée entre 2002
et 2007 puis entre 2012 et 2015 par
valérie pécresse l'actuelle candidate
les républicains pour les élections
présidentielles 2022 depuis 2010 est
jean noël barrot député modem
représentent les administrés de ce
territoire je pense pas que les français
s'intéressent aux législatives à ce
stade je pense qu'ils s'intéressent
d'abord qui s'intéressent à leur
quotidien et à l'impact qu'a le le la
pandémie et puis ensuite viendra le
temps de la présidentielle puis ensuite
le temps des critiques à la fois
territoire d'innovation de paris saclay
et poumons naturel de la vallée de
chevreuse la 2e circonscription des
yvelines s'étend de viroflay en passant
par vélizy-villacoublay versailles sud
jusqu à cerner la ville elle regroupe
près de cent vingt mille habitants dans
ses vingt communes du sud est du
département
la mobilité autour du rer b ou de la
future ligne 18 les thématiques autour
de la pandémie de la ruralité ou du
logement sont autant de préoccupations
sur ce territoire je mets la crise
sanitaire au premier rang des priorités
des questionnements sur les différents
sujets que je viens d'aborder sur la
sujet des mobilités sur le sujet des
nuits nord sur le sujet du logement et
de la construction de logements on a
essayé de travailler au plus près du
terrain avec toutes les parties
prenantes associé à ses associés
intéressés à ces problématiques avec les
élus locaux autres potentiels candidats
pascal thévenot en janvier 2016 pour
occuper la présidence de la région
ile-de-france valérie pécresse a été
contrainte de démissionner de son siège
à l'assemblée nationale une élection
législative partielle a été organisée
vainqueur le maire de vélizy
villacoublay devient député de la 2e
circonscription
mais lors du scrutin de 2010 est le
candidat des républicains s'est incliné
au second tour face à jean noël barrot
il avait obtenu 42 % des voix contre 58
% pour le candidat du modem en 2022
pascal thévenot participera à nouveau au
scrutin législatif
sans plus un territoire qui connaît bien
moi j'y suis né je suis enraciné j'ai
une implantation forte au niveau
associatif dans la circonscription avec
circonscription qu'est majan d'avoir une
petite france il ya donné que les foires
organisées kébé l'isi on a patrie - une
vie patrimoniale royal avec versailles
on à la veille de la bière la veille
deux choses une partie 50 ans l'une avec
magny les hameaux donc finalement on a à
peu près toutes les problématiques qu'on
peut retrouver au niveau national lors
des dernières législatives jean noël
barrot avait mis fin à soixante ans de
mandat à droite sur cette
circonscription
cette situation ne restera tel qu'une
parenthèse centriste où la majorité
présidentielle va-t-elle confirmer son
ancrage réponse en juin prochain
nadal ministre chargé de la ville s'est
vendu ce jeudi 20 janvier à mézières sur
seine objectif de la visite inauguré l
espace francs service de la commune un
accueil de proximité pour accompagner
les citoyens dans leurs démarches
administratives par exemple faire sa
déclaration d'impôts en ligne ou encore
son cd pôle emploi au programme de
l'inauguration visite guidée de la
structurer et présentations et des
différents services proposés
[Musique]
les cards au beau fils architecte
mondialement connue est mort vendredi 14
janvier à l'âge de 82 ans des suites du
coc vite 19 l'espagnol est notamment
connu dans les yvelines pour être le
concepteur des arcades du lac dont le
quartier de la source de riz à montigny
le bretonneux le reportage de mathilde
de franck ou et patrick jacq de dix
minutes
en ile-de-france il était célèbre pour
avoir réalisé les espaces abraxas à
noisy-le-grand la place des colonnes à
cergy pontoise ou encore la place de
catalogne à paris ricardo beau fils est
mort le 14 janvier à l'âge de 82 ans
emporté par le colis de 19 dans les
yvelines il était connu pour être le
concepteur des arcades du lac au sein du
quartier de lasours de riz à montigny le
bretonneux réalisé de 1978 à 1982
l'ensemble architectural est surnommé le
versailles du peuple ça touche un peu
comme tout le monde du x et à de
versailles le peuple a en moi ici tout
le monde peut venir y prendre un pique
nique y discuter un peu faire son sport
c'est vraiment services à la personne
plus déçu qu'il soit accéder si vite
mais bon on va le fait qu'on en parle
déjà c'est à dire qu' il va rester un
petit peu dans l'histoire déjà je dirais
que c'est
un quartier qui possède une architecture
très spécial
qui a tendance à ressembler au château
de versailles c'est ce que voulait
d'architecte il me semble et ce qui est
très bien c'est que c'est beaucoup
visité c'est très agréable à vivre c'est
très calme avec la pièce d'eau à côté il
y en a plein d'oiseaux migrateurs c'est
un quartier très très calme très
familial en fait on al'avantage que ce
soit complètement piétons du coup pour
les enfants c'est idéal l'architecte
novateur aimé réaliser l'impossible il a
construit 380 logements sur le bassin de
la sourderie le site devient
emblématique dans les années 80 il ya
beaucoup de grands noms qui sont de
l'architecturé qui sont associés à saint
quentin en yvelines
ricardo bofill fait partie de ces grands
noms c'est aussi une fierté dans le sens
où c'est la première grande réalisation
de vos fils
en france et c'est un ensemble qui a
toujours été emblématique quatre ans
plus tard riccardo beau fils a complété
son heure avec la construction de 200
logements baptisé les temples est
emplettes ce nouveau quartier est situé
de l'autre côté du lac à voisins le
bretonneux ces lieux ont inspiré de
nombreux artistes comme nekfeu soprano
et niño qui m'ont enregistrer leurs
cliques
[Musique]
et du sport à présent aujourd'hui tv
60,18 vous propose de découvrir le yoga
vignes asa une discipline sportive qui
permet à d'enchaîner plusieurs postures
physiques avec des exercices de
respiration
nous sommes allés découvrir ce style de
yoga à versailles un reportage de
mickael miro
aurait lâché les épaules
relâchées la mâchoire inférieure
et c'est votre visage
et connectez-vous à votre respiration à
chaque début de cours johanna invite ses
élèves à lâcher prise pour réaliser au
mieux leurs séances de yoga vinyasa
depuis une dizaine d'années cette
versaillaise pratiquer cette discipline
développés au cours du 20e siècle ça
qu'on pratique en musique souvent qui
est un petit peu plus dynamique puisque
en fait on enchaîne les postures au
rythme de la respiration
donc on va les tenir un peu moins
longtemps que dans une séance classique
de hatha yoga mais on va en faire plus
et on va demander un petit peu plus
d'engagement physique
vous l'aurez compris malgré l'ambiance
tamisée relaxante les cinq élèves
présents ce jour là vont transpirer
après un échauffement de dix minutes ils
enchaînent les postures en rythme avec
leur respiration céder à leurs autres
stars de bien dissocier chaque partie
expirez arrondissez on enrôle coccyx le
milieu le haut du dos on pousse sur
scène ces exercices ont pour but de
solliciter les muscles profonds les
muscles profonds c'est tout ce qui est
permettent de soutenir le squelette on
pense souvent aux trans vertes qui sont
les muscles du ventre plat au psoas
aussi qui peut être en cause dans les
mal de dos quand il n'est pas assez tiré
c'est le muscle qui relie la le fémur au
dos et ensuite on travaille aussi la
force dans les bras on travaille aussi
la souplesse aller les équilibres après
une heure là c'est en semble avoir porté
ses fruits c'est pas impressionnant
peut-être comme ça mais ça permet de
travailler l'équilibré les muscles
profonds et
quelque chose qui est sportif moi
j'avais beaucoup sous-estimé je pensais
que c'était facile et au final pas du
tout par exemple je fais de la
musculation à côté et maintenant j'avais
beaucoup mieux à passer tout ce qui est
pompeux on a vraiment renforcé même le
haut du corps et j'ai vraiment raffermit
à ma sangle abdominale ce que je pensais
pas du tout selon joanna cette
discipline est accessible à tous la
professeure conseille de faire une à
deux séances par semaine pour pouvoir
sculpté à la fois son corps et son
esprit si vous voulez tester le forfait
de 140 euros pour cinq cours
c'est la fin de ce journal merci à tous
de nous avoir suivis très bonne soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]